الحدث الابرز النصر يقدم نجمه العالمي
رونالدو والامير هاري يواصل خصام العائله
المالكه
وام كلثوم بين اهم مئتين مطرب ومطربه في
العالم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ما زال اسم نادي النصر السعودي ونجمه
الجديد اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو متصدر اخبار والعناوين فمن بعد ما
تم الاعلان عن تعاقد العالمي مع نجم كره
القدم رونالدو
والمنطلقت بالاخبار والفرح والاحتفاء ان
كان من خلال الصور اللي انتشرت الاستقبال
النجم البوتجالي في شوارع الرياض اللي
احتفلت بالنجم على طريقه الخاصه او من
خلال صور وفيديوهات الاستقبال لناشره
النادي
الوصول كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن بين الصور والفيديوهات في فيديو منتشر
بشكل كبير وعامل تفاعل جميل وهو لاصغر
مشجع مصراوي كان حامل علم نادي النصر وعم
بقلد حركه رونالدو الشهيره وهي القفز في
الهواء
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا انضمام نجم كره القدم
الى نادي النصر السعودي منه خبر
[موسيقى]
هي الحفله المقرر مساء اليوم وتحديدا مع
بعض اقل من ساعه من الان هو حفل تقديم
العالمي لنجمه الجديد كريستيانو رونالدو
المصري
حسب المعلومات
راح يكون في مؤتمر صحفي للنجم عليك
كريستيانو رونالدو ولي رئيس مجلس اداره
نادي النصر السعودي
رونالدو قميص نادي النصر
رونالدو حتى عام 2025 الاقبال على الحفل
فقط توقعات وتم تداول معلومات واخبار انه
اكثر من 130,000 مشجع عم يبحثوا عن تذاكر
لحضور حفله تقديم لكن تم الاعلان عن انه
رايح التذاكر راح يعود ل منصه احسان
الوطنيه للعمل الخيري
عن هذا الحدث الابرز ينضم الينا من داخل
وامام ملعب مرسول بارك في الرياض مراسله
العربيه فهد الشهري وعبد المحسن الحربي
نبدا مع فهد اهلا بك فهد
انقل لنا الاجواء الحماسيه من عندك ضعنا
في الصوره
[موسيقى]
اهلا مساء الخير للجوال جدا حماسيه
استعداد كبير توافق كبير قبل نصف ساعه فقط
تم فتح البوابات للجماهير جميعا
الادوات
الميوزك ايضا الذباب المتنقل للاضاءات
الممر الشرفي اللي كان يبدا فيه نادي ريال
مدريد اول من بدا بتقديم نجومي ولا اساطير
بدايه من كاكا ثم كريستيانو رونالدو
راح يتواجد اليوم في ملعب مرسول اقبال
كبير
ضخم احتفالات يبدوا انها ستكون يعني همم
مزامنه وتكون لائقه في هذا الاحتفال
الكبير بقدوم الاسطوره كريستيانو رونالدو
الجماهير في الخارج تحتفل بشكل هستيري
تنتظر القدوم واحتلال مدرجها اللي اعتقد
انه الملعب راح يكون فوق طاقه الاست-
الثعابيه راح اعتقد انه راح يكون
اعلى حضور جماهيري في تاريخ ملعب جامعه
الملك سعود وملعب مرسول بارك سيساعد على
ذلك انه اليوم كان في تعليق دراسه لا
دراسه العوائل حضاره كبار بشكل كبير طبعا
يوم ما كان في دراسه في مدينه الرياض
مناسبه الامطار الغزيره اللي من الصباح
الباكر احتفالات كبيره جيجي جاهز هذاك
المنصه الحمراء اللي تشاهدين هناك المنصه
الحمراء
اللي راح تقدم الكابتن كريستيانو رونالدو
الجمعيه تحتفل تستعد تستعد ساعه بالضبط ان
شاء الله راح يكون تقديم كريستيانو
رونالدو اول مره
تيشيرت فريق نادي النصر سننتقل الى عبد
المحسن الحربي ليضعنا في الاجواء خارج
الملعب
[موسيقى]
والمتوقع حضور ضخم لهذا الحفل الضخم ضعف
الاجواء
نعم الاجواء خارج الملعب لا تقل الحماس عن
داخل الملعب حيث يتوافق المئات من مشجعي
والالاف مشجعي ان النصر ومحبي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى مرسول باركلي الدخول وحضور
هذه الاحتفاليه الكبيره التي تقام لاول
مره على مستوى السعوديه حتى على مستوى
الشرق
اسيا همم
احتفاليه كبيره لاحد اساطير كره القدم
الذي نادي النصر كريستيانو رونالدو في
الحقيقه الجمهور بدا بالتوافق قبل ثلاث
ساعات من الان قبل وقت مبكر جدا لي يحصل
على مقاعدهم همم البوابات افتتحت قبل ما
يقارب النصف ساعه الى الساعه ودخل اغلب
الجمهور الى الداخل لا تزال عمليه الدخول
وتوافذ الجمهور الى داخل الملعب مستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه طبعا فقرات الحفل ستبدا بعد
ساعه قبل قليل همم الشاشه همم يا ابن
الخلف اا ذهبت الى الموقع الشرفي والدخول
الشرفي لمرسول بارك ربما هذا يشير الى قرب
وصول حافله فريق نادي النصر الذي سيجري
تدريبا
الجماهيريا في الملعب احتفالا بكريستيانو
رونالدو وربما حتى وصول كريستيانو رونالدو
الى الملعب حتى الان نحن نراقب الاجواء
حيث من متوقع كرستيانو رونالدو في ربما
الدقائق القليله القادم على ان يبدا الحفل
الساعه السابعه الحفل يتضمن العديد من
الفقرات منها لكريستيانو رونالدو كاليما ل
همم رئيس نادي النصر بالاضافه الى اغنيه
خاصه لكريستيانو رونالدو
وايضا سيقوم كريستيانو باهداء الجماهير
عدد من الكور ل- همم الجمهور الحاضر في
حفل هذا الليله لتقديم كريستيانو رونالدو
للجمهور للمره الاولى زي النصر وكذلك في
ملعب النصر
هل من وسائل اعلام اجنبيه لتغطيه هذا
الحدث
اللي فهد السؤال
بالفعل هنالك تغطيه كبيره جدا
[موسيقى]
لوسائل الاعلام حتى الان المؤكد ان 30
قناه حول العالم تنقل همم هذه همم هذه
الاحتفاليه الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو
بتقديمه في ملعب مرسول باركلي همم
نادي النصر وارتداء شعاري للمره الاولى
الكثير ايضا من وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيهاتها موجوده في داخل الملعب
لتغطيه هذا الحدث الكبير الكثير من
الوكالات الدوليه تواجدت ليس فقط اليوم
ولكن حتى منذ ايام حيث الاعلان الرسمي اذا
همم
القاره الاسيويه الاوروبيه والافريقيه وكل
القارات والكره الارضيه اليوم ستنتهي
المباراه
لمشاهده كريستيانو رونالدو للمره الاولى
خارج اوروبا
للحضور الى هذا ملعب الضخم كم يتسع اصلا
الملعب بيتسع ل 25,000 مشجع لكن اعتقد انه
حيكون في دخول لاكبر اليوم حيكون في دخول
اكبر من الدعوات كانوا اليوم انت عارفه
مباراه يعني مو مباراه عفوا حفل تقديم
وليس مباراه فاعتقد ان الملعب هيكون فيه
30,000 لاول مره في تاريخ هذه الملعب
اقبال كبير
لشراء التذكره فوق ال100,000
اريد ان اسالك عن المشاهير الذين حضروا
نعم نعم
شكرا جزيلا اداره نادي النصر واداره مرسول
البار
حه
وجه اداره النصر واداره الملعب مرسول
مبارك الدعوات اللي عده مشاهير على مستوى
كره القدم طبعا اللعيبه القدام النصراويين
اعضاء من وزاره الرياضه وايضا العديد من
المشاهير في مجال الفني والمجال الرياضي
في السعوديه وفي الخليج راح يحضروا اليوم
هذه الحفل للجميع اللي راح يكون على يعني
على قدر انتظار الاسطوره كريستيانو
رونالدو
[موسيقى]
فاصل ونواصل الحلقه
اشبه ما تكون بتلك التي عاشتها اوروبا منذ
اربعه قرون نظا
اوروبا عاند من محاكم التفتيش كانت معارك
طائفيه كانت مجازر ونحن الان ايضا نعاني
من التطرف نعانين من ظلاميات
فراس العربي الاسلامي تراث عظيم ولكنه
يستحق قراءه اخرى ويستحق فاهم الاخر
هل افهم من كلامك انه اي حركه اصلاح او
تغيير او تطوير لابد ان تاتي من خلال
الثورات والاضطرابات دكتور هاشم سؤال
مباشر مع خالد مدخلي الجمعه الخامسه
والنصف على شاشه العربيه
يشعر المرء بضروره للتساؤل
للاستفسار
عن قضايا تهم الملايين حول العالم يشعر
المرء بحاجه لايجاد ايجابات
عن اسئله تشكل الحاضر والمستقبل
كل الاسئله تبرح وكل الاخبار تلاقي
[موسيقى]
كل التفاصيل نقف عندها
اهلا بكم من جديد
تبدو انها مستمره فمن بعد ما تم بس سته
اجزاء من وثائقي
هايلكس واصل الامير هاريدو تصريحاته
العلنيه والمفاجاه بخصوص خلافته مع
العائله المالكه واكيد الجميع تابعه وشاف
الجدل اللي عملوه الوثائق واللي خرب
الدنيا
داخل المجتمع البريطاني ويبدا ان هو نحن
على مواعيد متعدده مع الفضائح واستمرار
الجدل الامير هاري بالوقت اللي الناس فيه
عم تنتظر اصدار كتابه في العاشر من الشهر
الجاري
ما راح يسكت ومستمر بيهتم الاعلان عن
مقابلتين مختلفتين معه لحتم عرضهم في نفس
اليوم واول مقابله لبرنامج سكس بنت وتعتبر
اول مقابله للتلفزيونيه امريكيه
للامير وصلت طفولته
وقال خلال مقطع دعائي في قابل انه في كل
مره حاول فيها القيام بشيء على الانفراد
كانت هناك احاطات وتسريبات وزرع قصص ضده
وضد زوجته فكم تعلمون شعار العائله هو لا
تشكو ابدا ولا تشرح ابدا اما التصريح
الثانيه العلني الثاني للامير هارب هو
كمان من خلال مقابله مع قناه اي تي في
البريطانيه واللي كمان اظهر فيها المقطع
ادعاء حاله من الشك والعالميه ولكن ضد
والد الملك تشارلز واخوه ولي العهد وليام
اللي ما اظهر لا هو ولا الملك تشارلز اي
استعداد للمصالحه معه لا قال فيها انه هو
عم يبحث عن عائله وليس عن مؤسسه انه بيرغب
باستعادتهم مشاهدينا انه المقابلتين راح
يتم بسهم في نفس التوقيت قبل يومين من نشر
مذكرات الامير
الجديد حول حياتك يعني يبدو انه كل هذه
الاحداث هو التصريحات لا شيء امام ما قد
يكون مكتوب داخل مذكرات الامير
كانت يبدو من عنوانها سبير او الاحتياطي
انها تحمل الكثير من الجدل والمفاجاه
وعن هذا الجدل المستمر تنضم الينا من لندن
الصحفيه جولسلين ايليا
اهلا بك يا جولين
اهلا بك يعني بعد ما كشف كل شيء تقريبا
الامير هاري عم كل خصوصيات العيله
والفضائح الجمهور البريطاني عن جد متشوق
يعرف المزيد من تلك الفضائح ام من كثره
الشكاوي يا اللي اطلقها هذه خلال فتره
الاخيره وصار في حاله انتعاض ضده ضد زوجته
بصراحه ااا نحنا ببريتانيا عم نحضر كانه
وقائع لمسلسل امريكي طويل او مسلسل تركي
اذا صح التعبير لانه في احداث كثير وفي
قنابل كثير وفي نشر غسيل كتير ولكن السؤال
اللي بيطرح نفسه الان قد ايه راح يكون بعد
عنده غسيل حتى ينشروا علنا عن عائله مهم
جدا عائله ملكيه مثل العيله اللي هو
بينحضرنا
انقسام هون بشارع البريطاني الغالبيه همم
تعبه ومن له من هذا الموضوع وفي رده فعل
سلبيه جدا على الامير هاري وعلى زوجته
بالتحديد مجانا يا اللي يقع عليها اللون
الاكبر وبيحسب اغلبيه البريطانيين يرون
على الرغم من كل الي قباحه فيه ولا قلوب
[موسيقى]
اللي عملوها من السته اه في ممكن فكروا
انه في نوع من التعاطف مع انه هي مات عملت
بالطريقه الي كان لازم تتعامل فيها وقصر
باكينغهام ما اعطاها الدعم اللي كان لازم
ولكن انقلب السحر على الساحر ولا اعتقد
بانه الشارع البريطاني او البريطانيين
يقفون مع الذي يجري الان ومع الفضائح
المتكلم
الصمت المطبق من العائله المالكي عاده
تسريبات عن العائله المالكي حاليا نرى ان
هناك الصمت مطبق حول الموضوع كيف تقرا هذا
المكان
بحسب بالمقتطفات يا اللي شفناها اليوم
بالنسبه للمقابلتين اللي راح تكون مع
اندرسون كوبر اا من سي بي اس والمقابله
الثانيه مع القناه الثالثه في بريطانيا
مع همم
تومب راتبي همم اللي بين فيها واللي هو
قالوا انه السكوت هو خيانه وهو يعني
الامير هاري جمله هايدا بانه ماشي تعليق
من قصر
الملكه همم
حاليا هي على راسها همم الملك
والملكه
بانه اذا قصر باكينغهام او حتى الملك نفسه
بقضيه القال والقيل والاتي اعظم لانه همم
لن تنتهي السلسله هنا في المقابلتين يوم
الاحد او مساء الاحد وانما هناك يعني بعض
الاخبار التي
راحه في الكتاب في كتاب السبير يوم
الثلاثاء القادم فلا اعتقد بان من مصلحه
الملك تشارج او من قصر باكينغهام التعليق
او او اقل من دقيقه هل ممكن ملك تشارلز ان
يخضع للضغوطات يعني نزع كل الالقاب عن
ابنه
من الممكن لان المساله اصبحت مساله تحدي
ومساله تجاريه همم وما يجري الان واعطاء
يعني القيام بهذه المقابلتين يوم الاحد
ترويش للكتاب الذي دفعوله عليه 20 مليون
دولار
فالمساله اصبحت مساله التجاره فهو يبيع
قصص عائلته للعيش لانه لا يعمل حاليا ضمن
المؤسسه الملكيه التي تركها هو يعني
عاش في الولايات المتحده مع زوجته ولكن
يعني هناك في تناقض كبير همم رايناه في
همم بعض المقتطفات ما في مقابله السي بي
اس بانه هو هو طبعا بان يعيش في الولايات
المتحده لانه يبحث عن الحريه الشخصيه وعن
الخصوصيه
لن ينتحر قريبا شكرا لك من لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ونعود الى الانجازات العربيه من الرياضه
الى الفن والانجاز هو تقليد لمجله امريكيه
نشرت قائمه لاعظم 200 مطرب ومطربه في
العالم ومن بين الاصوات كانت تواجد لصوت
عربي وحيد وهو المطرب المصريه ام كلثوم
لانه الكثير من الناس ولدوا باصوات ونغمه
مثاليه ولكن الذي هم اكثر هو الاصاله
والتاثير واتساع
تراث الفنان الثقفي كوكب الشرق اللي وصلت
للعالميه واحتلت المركز الواحد والستين
ضمن القائمه وما كانت فقط العربيه الوحيده
في القائمه بل تفوقت على مايكل جاكسون
بالعالم
جورج مايكل وفي تعريف المجله بتقريرها عن
ام كلثوم كتبت انه كوكب الشرق ليس لها
مثيل حقيقي بين المطربين في الغرب وتجاوز
تاثيرها العالم العربي وكان واضح هذا
التاثير عندما اعتبرها الديلان عظيمه
واستخدم الديونسي كلمات اغنيه انت عمري في
تصميم رقصتها عام 2016 طبعا هذا بالاضافه
للكثير من الفنانين الغربيين اللي اجمعوا
على عظمه كوكب الشرق التي كانت وما زالت
مناره والطريق الوحيد للوصول لقلوب
المحبين فليس هناك اجمل من العيش في قلب
ام كلثوم
ختام الحلقه تفاعلكم اليوم الى اللقاء
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
ومرت
ومرت الايام
[موسيقى]
ونسيت
ما اعرفش ازاي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]